you mentioned you go to a lot of pants
and you you see this phenomenon that
happens to a lot of experts and stars
yeah they get sort of bum-rushed yeah I
people hey can you help me can you do
this yeah yeah I have a major pet peeve
with that I go I go to LA not so much
panels but I got a lot of q and A's
again one of the blessings of being in
la actually lots of Q neighs with
directors and filmmakers and stuff after
the film and again it's like these
people are just absolutely mobbed you
know and I'm just saying they're in the
in the sea and I'm I'm just thinking
like you fools you know you fools why
first and foremost the person just
shared what's worth sharing number one
number two and most importantly this
person cannot help you buy you nobody
filmmaker you know now you guys film
courage going up to someone you have
something in place you have you have an
operation you have something that they
can include themselves in and engage in
you have something but the person with a
script the actor with a pretty face the
the the filmmaker with an idea you're
worth nothing to these people
professionally professionally nothing
most of the time socially to your worth
nothing you're wasting your time you're
wasting their time you look like a fool
I went to QA at the egyptian theatre in
hollywood one of my favorite theaters I
went to QA there Verner hurts i was
there oh my gosh you should have seen
the mob around this guy in the lobby
okay you it was it was scary it was like
the Beatles okay burner hurts ugh but
I'll never forget this I'll never forget
this I was on the periphery you know
because you have to exit you know I was
leaving there's this guy he must have
been about 22 years old he was in front
of Verner hurt sake
his way up you know and he said I'll do
anything because just I'll do whatever
you want on your set I just want to be
there you know watching you learning
from heat and Werner Herzog is a really
nice man it's it's evident in his films
and what I've seen him in person I don't
even remember what the poor guy said you
know in fact Vernon hurts I had
something called the rogue film school I
think you could actually take classes
with it what I would have told that guy
if I was burner huh was here's my card
make an original film not something you
made ten years ago make an original film
email it to me you know number one
number two and this is what I'm even
more passionate about with this
phenomenon as these people bum rush the
celebrity that can't do anything for
them they are leaving behind the people
that can do something for them you mean
the fellow nobody filmmaker that knows
how to operate a boom pole knows a good
decent amount of talented actors that
has an old but good camera I can help
you rather than go up two burner hertzog
why don't you turn to your left talk to
me and say hey how's it going man you
Vernon hertzog fan what do you do
filming all cool man do you have a card
cool check out your movies dialogue
that's the tragedy in the mob mentality
most people want to forget where it is
the helicopter ride to success yeah I
have to put in the suede equity worse it
seems like you're willing to do that
right post yeah how many people aren't
really worth that yeah they want just
the easy way out yeah you know say that
it's foolish you know and unfortunately
not what I don't know why I said
unfortunately but for some bizarre
reason I've talked to some of my friends
about this and we can't quite figure it
out but for some bizarre reason people
with that mindset are prone to pursue
entertainment type stuff it's I don't
know why because you don't see that
helicopter to success type mentality I
didn't see it in law school I can't
imagine someone in medicine thinking
that we're accounting or even
entrepreneurial business most everyone's
starting business knows it takes at
least five years to turn a profit or
whatever the statistics are but for some
reason and filmmaking and entertainment
in general like there's that mentality
and I don't know where it comes from or
why I just think it's foolish and it
leads to lots of heartache lots of debt
Oh lots of foolishness so I don't know
think it's sad
you